guest spots from last week your mom's
house had on Kevin Nealon and Daniel
Ricardo two bears 1K was Burton Tom Tom
and Bert flagrant had on Marquis
Brownlee kill Tony tonight is another
episode from skank Fest featuring Big
Jay oakerson Louis J Gomez and Dave
Smith Shane Gillis was a guest on the
Adam Friedland show and whiskey Ginger
had on Ari shaffir people don't
understand because specials are so
it's a comment but they happen a lot
more now yeah it's the biggest moment in
in a in a between a one for those who
are two year to five year period of a
Comics whole life totally it was almost
like after someone get past the comedy
store yeah some nothing thing like you
get 15 bucks now but we're all like we
did it yeah we conquered the world this
past weekend and Theo Vaughan talked
with Bubba Sparks Franco Quinones was on
tigerbelly The Joe Rogan Experience was
the entire sober October crew we might
be drunk with the bachelor party episode
and Bobby Kelly was on the Tim Dillon
show